[موسيقى]
عندما تلتقي السهام الحمراء بالنجوم
الفضيه في سماء سهل حشيش يكون الاداء
مبهرا وتشكيل متميزا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العرض
الجويريا بين المصريين والاجانب الذي اتى
بعضهم خصيصا الى سهل حشيش لمتابعه ومشاهده
العرض اه ماي قادس مميزين يا لهوي من عرض
رائع احببته كثيرا انا من برلين ولا لدينا
عروض جويه لمختلف الجنسيات ولكن هذا شيء
مختلف لقد احببت ما رايت
فكان فرصه جميله
[موسيقى]
البريطانيه يلتقي نظيره المصري من قوات
الجويه المصريه لتنفيذ هذا العرض الجويه
في سهل حشيش بالغردقه العرض جويرجاد ارشو
او عرض الغردقه
[موسيقى]
العرض الذي شاركت فيه قوات المظلات
المصريه وتشكيلات الاعلام استعرض مهارات
الفريقين وعاد بالفريق البريطاني الى
السماء مصر بعد غياب استمر 20 عاما
في الغردقه
الملازم
قاد احدى طائرات الفريق فوق قصر باكينغهام
في يونيو الماضي حيث شارك فريقه في
احتفالات العيد السبعين لجلوس الملكه
الراحله اليزابيث على العرش
العظيم ان اكون جزءا من هذه الفعاليات
[موسيقى]
بالتحليق فوق اهرامات الجيزه اختتم فريق
السهام الحمر جولته التي استغرقت خمسه
اسابيع شملت الدول الخليج ومنها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه حيث اشترك مع فريق
الصقور السعوديه بعرض جوي متميز في الرياض
[موسيقى]
اما فريق النجوم الفضيه المصري فقد شارك
قبل اربعه اشهر بعرض متميز مع فريق كوريا
الجنوبيه فوق اهرامات الجيزه
في شهر اغسطس
النهارده
للقوات المسلحه المصريه
والجانب الانجليزي ده هيقول ان احنا في
علاقات متميزه بيننا بيننا وبين جميع دول
العالم
فهذه العروض الجويه المشتركه تهدف لتعزيز
روابط الصداقه بين الدول فضلنا عن التدريب
والترويج لمناطق ومعالم سياحيه راندا ابو
العزم لصباح العربيه سهل حشيش الغردقه